[Music]
how cool would it be to see a real-life
t-rex if only that one fatal asteroid
never hit the earth would dinosaurs
still be alive today would they have
evolved what humans have survived this
long could we ever learn to coexist this
is what if and here's what would happen
if dinosaurs never went extinct until 66
million years ago dinosaurs of all
shapes and sizes roamed the earth
intelligent adaptable and sometimes
weighing as much as two jet planes it's
hard to believe that it only took one
rock to wipe them all out of course this
was no ordinary Rock the asteroid that
took out the dinosaurs was nine miles
wide and hit earth with the destructive
force of ten billion her Oshima bombs
the radioactive shockwave obliterated
everything for hundreds of miles in
every direction and 75% of all species
on earth went extinct if that asteroid
had hit just a little earlier a little
later or even a few miles off course we
would be living in a very different
world today
the rock that killed the dinosaurs
struck the shallow waters of Mexico's
Yucatan Peninsula had it landed a little
farther off the coast in a deeper part
of the ocean the water might have
absorbed some of the blasts along with
its devastating effects on the
atmosphere but even if the asteroid
missed the earth dinosaurs would have to
survive several significant global
events in order to make it to the
present day 55 million years ago
temperatures rose the climate was 8
degrees hotter than it is today
rainforests crowded and vegetation
flourished herbivores would have adapted
and thrived but they'd have started to
look a little different the plants of
this period were less nutritious and
easier to digest
meaning dinosaurs would likely shrink in
size since their new diet wouldn't have
as much energy roughly 20 million years
after that South America and Antarctica
split creating a cooler and drier world
climate during this period long-legged
fast-moving dinosaurs would have evolved
to travel the huge grasslands stretching
out across the globe compared to mammals
of this period dinosaurs held
significant advantages such as having
more teeth and better eyesight
considering the dinosaurs were already
so advanced scientists wonder whether
mammals would have evolved at all if
dinosaurs hadn't gone extinct it's
likely that the big animals we know
today would have been prey the dinosaurs
but remember humans evolved alongside
woolly mammoths and saber-toothed cats
while those species didn't survive the
ice ages of 2.6 million years ago given
the evolutionary traits of some
dinosaurs there's a chance they might
have persisted but what about us could
we handle freezing temperatures and huge
terrifyingly vicious predators and they
say running keeps the body warm but that
might also make you taste better
in an alternate universe if we did
survive alongside these prehistoric
beasts it's possible we could see a real
live t-rex on a protected reserve not
unlike Jurassic Park human population
growth and excessive hunting would have
driven larger dinosaurs to near
extinction today they would most
certainly be an endangered species but
those that shrank and adapted over
millions of years could coexist
peacefully among us in fact some
actually do where do you think pigeons
came from it's hard to believe that
birds were once the size of biplanes but
then again it's hard to believe that
with a slight twist of fate we might
have walked with Dinosaurs
or we might have become dinosaur chow
and not have evolved at all but seeing
is believing at what if so if you've got
a passion for the incredible than keep
watching
[Music]